I wasn't going to talk about this
because I know that it's waiting into a
minefield the likes of which I may not
be able to stumble out of but it's got
to be discussed at this point and I'm
talking about rapper and hip-hop artist
Kanye West's recent comments about
slavery and Donald Trump I've never
liked Kanye West I've never liked his
music I've always found it to be
repulsive as a person which is why it
might surprise some people that I'm
actually not ready today to go on the
attack per se against Kanye West because
I think there's a really good chance
he's genuinely suffering from
psychological illness and that it's
really sad or that he's joking around
and I don't really think the things even
he's been saying sound like jokes to me
but they're not the things somebody
would say seriously if they're of sound
mind and I know some will say David
don't excuse stupidity by blaming it on
mental illness that's not what I'm doing
I genuinely think there's a good chance
this is not a well person and this all
started last week when Kanye West
tweeted a picture of himself wearing a
bright red make America great again hat
which made people question what is it
about Donald Trump that Kanye West likes
it led to Kanye ending up at gossip show
TMZ's newsroom where he said that he
believes 400 years of enslaved black
people was a choice at least to some
degree and he appeared on the show with
this truly depraved favorite by the way
of the so called internet free speech
warrior Enclave named Candace Owens
let's listen to it it's a couple minutes
long it's worth it we're playing only
video because I think TMZ is aggressive
with copyright claims let's take a
listen to what was said I don't think
people necessarily understand what
happened last week with the great
American make America great again hat
what are you trying to do with the
message you're sending well it was
really just my subconscious it was a
feeling I had you know like people were
taught how to think we're taught how to
feel we don't know how to think for
ourselves we don't know how to feel for
some people say feel free but they don't
really want us to feel free and I felt a
freedom and first of all just doing
something that everybody tells you not
to do I just love Trump that's my boy he
like you know it's like so many rappers
you look at a video of Snoop Dogg
love and trunk but then he get in the
office and I didn't love him like Trump
is one of raps favorite people right but
we we talked about this that before he
was elected president people in hip-hop
big it was it was an in thing to put
Donald Trump in your rhyme somewhere by
the way I am in hip-hop but I'm not just
in hip-hop I'm a black person in a black
community but I'm not just I feel like
one thing is people try to minimize me
to artists hip-hop black community yeah
I'm always gonna represent that but I
also represent the world when you hear
about slavery for 400 years for 400
years that's not like a choice like he
was there for 400 years and it's all
y'all you know like it's like we're
we're mentally in prison
all right so this went on longer and
later on Kanye took to Twitter to try to
clarify or explain and he said something
like once again I'm being attacked for
presenting new ideas the reason I
brought up 400 years was because we
can't be mentally imprisoned for another
400 and apparently that clarification
didn't go over too well because he then
deleted it from Twitter so it's really
important number one to understand this
for what is said and number two not to
analyze it for something that it isn't
or more deeply than it needs to be
analyzed so the idea here is Wow
famous black guy and entertainment guy
two communities that are statistically
not big supporters of the Republicans in
the Republican Party saying he loves
Trump slavery was a choice sounds like
the alt-right there are people online
saying the reason Kanye is getting
attacked for what he said is because
he's not playing the role that he's
expected to play as a black entertainer
and that he just has different ideas and
you're just not allowed to do that
because Hollywood and the liberal elite
don't allow for dissension in the ranks
or whatever Kanye's getting slammed
because he said dumb things that have no
evidence behind them whatsoever period
whether it's a black guy or not or
someone on my youtube comment thread or
a political commentator comments like
black people chose to be or to remain
slaves for 400 years what is the sort of
intellectual value of that I would argue
effectively nothing and in the end this
may be nothing more than an attempt to
promote Kanye West's upcoming albums
what's clear is that sometimes in order
to really understand something you need
to look at multiple layers and do a
super deep analysis and understand the
various ways in which good points might
be made not here right this is just
someone who's saying nothing remotely
deeper interesting it's being used by
some horrible elements of the American
right to their advantage and there are
three options here and it's the Trump
playbook right there there were always
three options when it came to Trump and
his supporters outrageous incompetent or
mentally ill and I don't say any of
these three and joking right Kanye West
maybe is being salacious and incendiary
merely for self-promotion which is
horrible
maybe he's saying uninformed things
which he doesn't really know anything
about or he actually might be mentally
ill and that wouldn't be something to
make fun of as I've said before it would
just be sad because when I listened to
that video it doesn't sound like a well
person to me but in any case number one
the comments shouldn't be celebrated and
number two we shouldn't pay them more
attention beyond ensuring that the
comments don't end up doing damage to
communities that we care about and when
the alt-right starts saying wow guys
making a lot of sense that's when it
actually does start to do damage to
those communities that we do care about
send me your thoughts I know there will
be people who disagree with me I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show support for
today's show comes from ever quote
America's largest online marketplace for
auto insurance only 5% of drivers pay
under $50 a month for auto insurance
nationally but ever quote is helping to
change that with a proprietary matching
algorithm that helps you find the right
coverage at the right price and in fact
data shows that users who find their
auto insurance through ever quote save
an average of five hundred and thirty
six dollars per year
no wonder over 300,000 shoppers use ever
quotes insurance matching services every
day take advantage of ever quotes
cutting-edge data and analytics and go
to every quote dot-com slash Pakman to
compare coverage options today